welcome to meet the Germans I'm excited
to have a very special guest with me
today some of you may already know
was--let Hasan azeemi an Afghan German
journalist and presenter here at
Deutsche Welle welcome westland great to
be here Cade thank you well today we're
going to talk about four pretty direct
questions you should be prepared to
answer in Germany
why is that because Germans sometimes
tend to say and ask whatever is on their
mind
[Music]
so was--let germans are known abroad for
being directs but do you agree with that
or is that just a stereotype well many
Germans might not consider themselves
direct but compared to other cultures
they definitely are when it comes to
asking certain questions they certainly
do not shy away from just asking and not
being too polite we asked a few Germans
whether they think Germans are direct
good flight to Detroit invasion director
it's another Byam and feeling quilt ruin
Zinta Lloyd Isaiah who flee only flower
in Deutschland sucht been shown my mayor
bus owner Felicia's directons cos ished
about concerts which finished as - Fargo
mine and Kung Lao Boris des deutschen
directs and when some fool Spygate some
brush pierre-jean Monsieur Myron what's
he doing Azu Azu only - a consultant on
a tech genus leader in direction got him
a badly Mac - of unified as wasn't shown
wasn't there any gentleman with an under
and man's action vasanas off you'd fight
something I get asked a lot is where are
you from and what exactly makes that a
direct question well if you don't look a
certain way they just assume that you're
not from Germany so how do you respond
to the question well I just say I was
born in Afghanistan I grew up in Germany
because if I would just say that I'm
German which I am they would bombard me
with ten other questions of where I'm
actually from my impression is that your
age is more important in Germany than
say in the u.s. Urban's can sometimes be
pretty direct when it comes to asking
how old you are especially on your
birthday and a person's age is always
mentioned in news articles - even if
it's not relevant to the story in
Afghanistan most people don't even know
their birthday really how can you not
even know your birthday it's not just
important and only children celebrate
their birthdays and sometimes you just
lose track of hold you actually are what
we both come from countries Afghanistan
and the United States that are covered a
lot in the media do you also get asked
often what you think about the political
situation in Afghanistan well yes if I
say that I'm from Afghanistan I always
get a surprised face and then I get
asked about the current security
situation and what the solution could be
in many cultures politics are actually a
taboo topic unless of course you know
the other person very well but I get
asked here a lot what I think about the
political situation in the US and even
who I voted for
well you often get treated as if you
were some kind of a political expert
it's actually employed in Germany to
talk about politics but when it comes to
people from foreign countries this rule
somehow does not apply my feeling is
that Germans also tend to be more direct
about asking what your religion is I
often get told that I'm probably not
very religious or practicing my Muslim
faith because I'm not bringing a
headscarf really but even if you're a
Christian like me then there tend to be
just two categories here you have the
Catholic state church and the partisan
state Church when I first moved to
Germany I also found it odd that even
the government is direct about asking
you about your religion but that's
because the church tax here is organized
by the state even though Germans can't
be direct they can usually handle a
direct reply if you don't want to answer
their question so was--let how would you
deal with that situation well maybe I'm
not German enough because to me it's
very impolite to just refuse it to
answer a question but many Germans will
just say they don't want to answer or
the question is too personal for them
well was--let thank you very much for
sharing your experiences here I meet the
Germans and thank you for watching how
direct are people in your culture
provide a comment and share your
thoughts come back soon for more from
meet them sermons
[Music]
you